have been wired by how much sugar I can
a barista for a year now I've been a
barista for about a year and a half I've
been to Bursa for about eight years I've
been a free stuff for over three years
and today we're guessing what's in
Starbucks secret menu drinks
I don't think I've ever ordered like
Starbucks secret menu before thank you
iced tea their shade I'm more of a tea
girl so bring on the drinks man pink
like pumpkin spice I think it's like
melon with cinnamon yeah you are 100%
correct
really you are 1,000 percent correct
it's about to get really exciting all
right is this a pumpkin spice drink Wow
it tasted like a pumpkin spice drink
tastes like a pumpkin pie but almost has
like chai taste to it
nutmeg maybe he's a little like caramel
or something
this one's probably the non-coffee
version yeah it's a definitely creme
crappuccino with the cream base no
[Music]
that's it pretty it's a pretty basic
Beast but you know that's why everyone
loves it this is more like a dessert
like it's a fun after jerky thing doing
the secret menu they don't say though
I'm telling you think of that I talk but
casamento say what's cinnamon toast and
you work out stomachs for eight years
nut Starbucks I've been eating coffee
like the best
Oh MOCA
I know it's look listen looks like a cut
more of a coffee drink bold bold
opinions
yes Haysbert normals yeah it's I'm
getting lots of vibes the phone is a
little bit dissipated so maybe not even
like originally like milk ohm and maybe
would be an almond oh yeah is just like
a like a plain latte
maybe this was in a secret menu right
this just tastes like a vanilla latte
from Starbucks matter if not is this
vanilla latte like a cookie except I
don't know it's got like some sass to it
like a little bit of bitter like talking
toffee I always say this is a vanilla
cappuccino
I suck up their game with this straw
that's toffee but it's definitely toffee
coffee this is the year-round
I just taste burnt yeah but it's like
thick so might be at the bottom you know
we might not taste it hmm
the bottom at the bottom at the bottom
yeah love that left that for her trying
not taking chunks of it bring on the
next one I see a frappe
I see chips that's for sure
cookies and cream with yes I would heavy
cream looks like a melted Blizzard need
to get from like dare you
it smells pretty pretty
oh no that's possible was that fruit oh
it tastes pretty it's like I like drink
perfume or something what is this I'm
shook that is not a boysenberry of all
the berry choice when do you find in a
bush like on a trail I don't berries and
bushes raspberry oh yeah strawberry we
should get strawberry first I taste
asbury a vanilla bean Java chips then
one of the floaters is my question this
is like a lot of syrup put together a
chia seed maybe I would call this a
raspberry truffle I would call this the
fairy fart because it's pissing me off
but also sweet in that sense
raspberry you guess when I do I just
tasted raspberry y'all wanted a twist I
was right the entire time but also wrong
I feel like you had a lot of sugar oh
hey I see more spices no I just want
cinnamon I would say oh it's me look at
that smell that
do you smell fall I smell crunchy leaves
and serial killers I love it yes Friday
the 13th it's today mama we have Jason
we have via Michael Myers we have all of
our stabby guides from the movies in
autumn it's a fall thing
I think it's hazelnut is it good maybe
think of like holidays hazelnut praline
that's what that is
it's definitely a really I feel like I'm
being wired by how much sugar is it's
like burnt sugar maybe what's that does
not taste like cinnamon toast crunch I'd
rather just have like a bowl of cinnamon
toast crunch valid okay alright it was
good having your Starbucks experience it
definitely helped an excessive amount of
sugar I'm not used to drinking so much
stuff in my coffee where can you find it
you have to whisper into a baristas ear
and they'll be like have you done it
[Music]